nous lino ventura se trouve maintenant
en direct depuis le centre de sèvres le
centre personnages en compagnie
d'isabelle meichler une ouverture à
après trois ans est ce que la rancune
est oublié maintenant ils ont tourné oui
oui vous entendrez bien sûr d'ailleurs
il faut oublier tout ça ça n'a plus
aucune importance que principal est le
plus important c'est de voir ses enfants
heureux le reste ne compte pas et
comment allez-vous poursuivre cette
action vous allez toujours vous servir
de votre renom pour arriver à créer
d'autres foyers de la sorte
écoutez j'ai j'aimerais que d'autres
aussi prennent un peu le relais parce
que je pense que ce que nous avons fait
l maman tu rémois depuis 20 ans
heureusement entouré par une équipe
d'amis fidèles qui s'est joint à nous
parce que sinon ça aurait été impossible
et je pense que maintenant qu'on a donné
un certain exemple j'aimerais bien que
dans d'autres régions se fait par par
des gens qui reprennent un petit peu le
flambeau mais ce que je voulais ce que
je voulais dire avant toute chose car
pour moi c'est le but principal est de
cette interview vous allez bien voulu
m'accorder je vous en remercie à pons
avant toute chose ce que je voulais dire
c'était que de montrer cet institut afin
que tous les gens qui nous ont aidés qui
nous ont donné de l'argent ou voix au a
terminé cet argent voilà s'est
concrétisée et s'agitent mais par dessus
tout il faut dire que cet argent n'a pas
servi uniquement à cet institut nous
sommes en train bientôt nous avons
inauguré quatre autres instituts que ce
soit pézenas après à saint maximin
dans les eaux du var nous avons d'autres
dossiers en cours qui sont qui sont en
très bonne voie notamment sur l'ouest de
la bretagne à nice est évidemment
l'ambition serait de couvrir le
territoire de ce genre en institut mais
je pense qu'il faut avec d'autres
nouvelles il faut justement lordon lino
ventura combien des handicapés mentaux
concerne personnage mais personnage ne
couvre ne couvre pas d'aidé aux
handicapés du pente au personnage est
une institution qui aide les autres
institutions mois voilà moi je suis un
collecteur si vous voulez je suis un
collecteur d'argent ça c'est mon travail
est d'aider des organismes nous écrivent
et nous disent voilà il nous manque tant
où il nous faut temps pour que nous
puissions construire un institut digne
de ce nom pour héberger des enfants
comme ça et nous on les aide
voilà j'ai ouvert sont fait construire
en fait on est on est des supports si
vous voulez merci lino ventura et bonne
chance merci d'avoir accepté de répondre
à nos questions mais le vieil et
aquariums du trot 4